all right everybody welcome back to an
unboxing we haven't done one of these
for a while uh we've actually got a very
special one today
we've got a special package a mystery
package I've yet to open this
from the artist who is the artist of
Scoops from MTG goldfish and turns out
it's actually someone I know from New
Zealand uh they go by the name of podgy
panda or Richard
um so thank you very much it was such a
funny conversation because I I actually
used to collect their their MTG tokens
in New Zealand I I worked for a shop
called hobby Master uh they had a bunch
of different tokens and I collected them
they were really cool and turns out he's
the artist of Scoops anyway got secret
package for open we've also got a
collector booster because you know it's
one of those so without further Ado
let's get into this and while we're
opening this package
you want to say
big huge thank you to everybody who's
been supporting the channel recently
really means a lot I hope you've all
been enjoying the content obviously Lord
of the Rings and all of that right
around the corner got some super
exciting things
uh obviously future Tom who's going to
be editing this video If there's
anything private in here we'll we'll
edit this out
[Music]
oh snap
you already see some cool things in here
all right
let's go I think these These are
actually the the tokens I have let's
look at these goodies here first
oh sick
so we've got some podgy Panda stickers
just casually all of his
personal information
oh look at this so nice
pizza slice Panda pin
donut pin wow these are freaking
adorable
all right
and we've got let me
scissors to open these
are awesome
here we go we've got our
very own Sun named
monk token
angel
elf Warrior
wolf token
Elemental
pack rack clones nice
drazy Scion
these are so cool obviously you can see
uh if you want to check out his website
go to podipander.com there'll be links
below to everything oh so many of these
Hasty Elementals
goblins
nice little spirits
and I think that's about it these are so
cool
so once again big shout out to Pochi
Panda AKA the artist of scoops lots of
awesome artwork all his links will be in
the description down below make sure to
check him out
and check out his stuff
now for the last little thing we have a
collector booster let's quickly
let's see if we can end the video with a
with a Ragga van
all right let's do this
preening champion
Bola Slinger
Sunday Gateway
deep God Anchorage the week
all right forexian Awakening
we're gonna battle invasion of egomon
gorgeous Mountain
oh nice Aaron ingada foil
Franco and torbjorn
in the L drain frame
oh spoilers
we've got a schema Thief for the
Commander pack this is actually a really
sick Commander card I need to run one of
my decks
nice Finn the Fang Bearer foil and
moti celebrant of bounty don't get the
invocation one I wish we did and come on
bloated processor foil is that it
oh
we've got Anna fenza kintree Spirit oh
that's not like scratches down the front
of it there
damn yeah you see the scratches on the
front there
[Music]
and treasure token
alrighty well there we go once again
shout out to podgy Panda for all these
awesome tokens that I can't wait to
build decks around now just to make sure
I can use all of them
links down below I hope you guys enjoyed
it once again thank you so much for all
the support on the channel it's been
absolutely wild these last couple of
weeks
as I said plenty of content to come
thank you so much for your support
I'll see you guys in the next one